Pietro Wilson tossed and turned as the nightmares
from the previous day filled his dreams.
In his restless sleep he watched the slaughter
of his colleagues at Site-22.
The unknown men who entered the facility had
gunned down everyone who worked there, everyone
except Pietro.
He remembered running deeper into the facility,
only to be cornered in a windowless concrete
room.
There he had found SCP-5000, an exclusionary
suit, that allowed him to become undetectable
to human senses.
It was a step beyond invisibility.
He successfully made it out of Site-22, but
the eyes of the men he killed to get away
haunted him.
Pietro had never taken a life before.
The only solace was that it felt like the
suit he was wearing had taken over, so his
actions were not technically his own.
But he had to wonder, what would he have done
without the suit?
Would he still have killed another human to
escape?
After leaving the facility Pietro had made
his way to an SCP safehouse.
This was where he now lay.
The slaughter of hundreds at Site-22 was bad,
but what he found when he turned on the news
at the safehouse was worse.
SCPs had been let loose around the world and
were killing people by the millions.
What was going on?
Pietro was startled awake from a nightmare.
He was hyperventilating, but his body almost
immediately recovered, and his breathing slowed.
A heads up display flashed on infront of his
eyes.
Pietro Wilson was still contained within SCP-5000.
The suit would not let him go.
He instinctively went to rub his eyes, but
the metal hands of the suit just clanked against
the helmet that covered his head.
He wanted out of this suit!
Pietro stood up and walked over to the television.
He reached out to turn it on but paused.
He thought: Do I really want to see how bad
things have gotten since I fell asleep?
But he had to know.
He was filled with dread as the TV came on
and he saw the first images.
The world looked as if it was ending, and
it seemed like the SCP Foundation was responsible.
How could this be?
They were supposed to protect humanity not
destroy it.
Pietro needed to uncover the truth behind
what was happening.
SCP-5000 had a log entry function that he
could use to record everything he uncovered.
Even if he didn’t make it out of this alive,
maybe one day someone would find the suit
and be able to access what he had learned.
The date of his first journal entry was February
1, 2020.
As Pietro watched the carnage unfold on TV,
he began to put together the pieces of what
he had witnessed himself.
He knew a special-ops squad had executed everyone
at Site-22 where he worked.
He knew that the SCPs had been let loose.
He knew the world was ending… but why?
As Pietro pondered this, a newscaster appeared.
“What you have just witnessed are reports
from around the world of monsters ravaging
cities and towns.
This all started with a mysterious message
from an organization that calls itself the
SCP Foundation.
Their ruling body, named the O5 Council, released
the following statement: ‘For those who
are not currently aware of our existence,
we represent the organization known as the
SCP Foundation.
Our previous mission centered around the containment
and study of anomalous objects, entities,
and other assorted phenomena.
This mission was the focus of our organization
for more than one-hundred years.
Due to circumstances outside of our control,
this directive has now changed.
Our new mission will be the extermination
of the human race.
There will be no further communication.”
He couldn’t believe what he was seeing.
The SCP Foundation had declared war on the
human race.
How could this be?
What had led to the O5 council changing their
entire mission from protecting humanity to
ending it?
Could it be possible that a powerful SCP had
taken control or influenced the council’s
decision?
Pietro turned on the radio, flipped through
TV channels, and scoured the internet for
information on what had happened over the
past 24 hours.
The first image he saw was a human-like creature
with arms and legs twice as long as they should
have been, with deep black eyes, and a mouth
curled up into a silent scream showing teeth
as sharp as razor blades.
From the files he could access Pietro learned
that this was SCP-096, a creature that was
docile until someone saw its face, at which
point the SCP would start to shriek and cry,
before hunting down whoever saw its face and
slaughtering them.
He quickly changed the channel.
The file said that even if SCP-096 was seen
on a screen, it would find the viewer and
tear them limb from limb.
Surely that couldn’t be true.
There were potentially millions of people
who had just seen it on TV.
What would happen to them?
What would happen to him?
On the next channel was footage of a gigantic
animal in the middle of the ocean.
This was SCP-169, a leviathan from the Pre-Cambrian
era.
The creature was around 5,000 kilometers long
and slowly swam just below the surface of
the ocean.
The feed suddenly changed to footage of devastating
tsunamis and destruction caused by earthquakes.
When SCP-169 had been awoken from its slumber
by the Foundation detonating nukes on its
back, it began trying to escape the danger.
The movement of the massive creature caused
natural disasters, destroying coastal communities
around the world.
On another channel Pietro watched as the chancellor
of Germany gave a speech, announcing that
the country was declaring war on the SCP Foundation.
Off camera the sound of a tinkling bell could
be heard.
A man dressed as a Victorian era butler entered
and picked up a pen from the Chancellor's
desk.
He approached the Chancellor and raised the
pen in the air as the camera cut away, but
the sound of gunshots and yelling could be
heard before the feed went dead.
The news reported that similar events involving
world leaders by the exact same butler had
been occurring since the SCP Foundation changed
its mission.
Pietro searched through the suit’s files
to try and figure out what was happening and
found that SCP-662 must have been connected.
Next was a strange skin disease plaguing New
York and Delhi designated SCP-610 that covered
its host in rashes and boils before seeking
to take over their bodies.
Finally some good news though, as the outbreak
looked to be contained by the combined efforts
of the Global Occult Coalition and the Church
of the Broken God.
And then some bad news, as SCP-682 had also
been released.
A massive crocodilian monster, it’s sole
mission was to destroy all life.
It was fueled by hatred for living things,
making it the perfect tool of the O5 Council’s
new stated mission.
Pietro had heard rumors of SCPs that could
instantly end the world, but clearly the Foundation
hadn’t gone down this route… yet.
Did they want to keep the rest of the planet
intact, or maybe there were hold outs in the
SCP Foundation who were trying to stop the
O5 Council from carrying out their mission?
All Pietro knew was that right now, there
were some real nasty SCPs running around wreaking
havoc.
Pietro suddenly heard an explosion in the
distance.
Far away, but still close enough to make him
nervous.
Maybe he was better off staying in the safehouse
and waiting out the apocalypse.
The suit was keeping him healthy, nourished,
and undetectable to foes.
Any sane person would have remained there
in seclusion and safety, but Pietro needed
answers.
He felt it was his responsibility to log and
try to make sense of everything the SCP Foundation
was doing.
He brought up a map of SCP sites in the area
on his display.
The closest was Site-19.
It was time to venture out into the end of
the world and find some answers.
But he was about to be faced with even more
questions.
On the way to Site-19, Pietro came across
something strange - a squad of Foundation
soldiers in a clearing.
They were standing at attention as their commander
paced back and forth, up and down the line.
The soldiers' uniforms had the insignia “MTF
Epsilon-6” embroidered on them.
The commander stopped in front of the first
soldier in the line, clapped her hands, and
informed the soldier she would be beginning
the check now.
The commander pulled out a long knife and
plunged it into the soldier’s shoulder.
Strangely, the soldier did not move, make
a sound, or react in any way.
She moved to the next soldier and repeated
the same process.
This continued down the line until she reached
the eighth soldier.
This time when the commander stabbed the shoulder
of the soldier, he noticeably winced and cried
out in pain.
The commander shouted “got a live one!”
Pietro watched as the soldiers raised their
guns and fired at the one who had cried out.
He dropped to the ground.
The commander moved on to the last soldier
and put the knife in his shoulder.
There was no reaction.
“Alright we’re clear,” yelled the commander.
“Let’s move out!”
Pietro waited until the squad was out of sight
and made his way to the corpse lying on the
ground.
He scavenged weapons and basic medical supplies,
then he buried the body and recorded what
he had seen in SCP-5000’s log.
He had no idea why this soldier was killed,
or why the others didn’t feel pain.
Maybe they weren’t human at all?
Maybe it was a squad of SCPs that had a human
infiltrate their ranks?
None of this makes sense, Piertro thought,
before continuing on.
Upon reaching Site-19, Pietro found it in
disarray, and worse, practically all of the
SCPs that were held at the site had breached
containment.
He was able to walk into the compound unnoticed
and deep in the facility he found scientists
and researchers going about their business
as if they had no idea what was happening
out in the world.
They must have been following the orders of
the O5 Council.
Pietro listened in on conversations about
how to create the maximum number of human
casualties, and which SCP should be released
next.
He felt a deep hatred for the people in this
facility.
How could they be so casual about wiping out
humanity?
As he observed more of the workers at Site-19,
he noticed something strange.
Everyones’ eyes were cold and dead, like
there was no humanity left in them, as if
something had gotten to these scientists and
removed the very souls from their bodies.
Pietro stealthily stole a senior staff member’s
credentials and found an empty office where
he could access logs from the facility, to
try and get a better idea of the timeline
of events that led to the SCP Foundation’s
war on humanity.
He logged into the mainframe and brought up
entries from the end of the previous year.
He found that late in 2019 a project called
‘PNEUMA’ became of great interest to the
O5 council.
From what Pietro could tell, the project had
something to do with the collective human
consciousness, also called the psychospace.
Apparently, SCP researchers had a breakthrough
in mapping out the psychospace.
Unfortunately, many of the files had been
redacted, and there was no way for Pietro
to access the unredacted version.
After ‘PNEUMA’ had been brought to the
attention of the O5 Council, a series of orders
were sent to all senior staff and site directors
but frustratingly these orders had also been
redacted.
All he could see was that after the orders
were sent out, a wave of resignations were
submitted across the Foundation.
Suspiciously, a wave of suicides had also
occurred at roughly the same time.
What was in these orders?!
The 05 council then sent out a number of files
to all senior staff and site directors with
instructions to disseminate the materials
among those serving under them, after which
both the resignations and deaths immediately
ceased.
Pietro searched everywhere for what was in
those files, but like so much of the SCP database,
this information had been redacted as well.
What was clear was that the SCP Foundation
had begun gearing up for the extermination
of humanity the following year.
The entry log for February 1, 2020 read: “Mobile
Task Forces are dispatched to all Exclusionary
Sites to execute all personnel.
Immediately following the conclusion of these
missions, the Foundation declares war on humanity.”
This was where Pietro Wilson’s journey had
started.
He slammed his hands down on the computer
monitor in frustration.
The suit absorbed all of the impact and crushed
the monitor in half.
Pietro moved to a new, non smashed computer,
and logged in again.
This time he brought up the most current entries
to see what the O5 Council was up to recently
to see if there were some answers in the present.
The SCP Foundation had been busy while he
was making his way to Site-19.
They had released SCP-1048 in Paris, which
now led a horde of bears down the Champs Elysées.
In the distance Pietro thought he could almost
make out a massive red teddy bear walking
between the buildings.
The SCP Foundation was also launching counterattacks
on any organization that tried to oppose them.
They used SCP-1290 to hurl projectiles at
the Global Occult Coalition’s base.
They were also using SCP-1440 to brainwash
people and convince them that they needed
to riot.
This caused widespread destruction as people
panicked and were trampled to death.
Pietro thought it was sad that such a kind
looking old man could cause so much destruction.
He recorded as much as he could before deciding
that it was time to get out of Site-19.
Although SCP-5000 still made him undetectable,
he couldn’t shake the feeling that the lifeless
eyes of the staff were beginning to look his
way more and more often.
As Pietro exited Site-19, the sky glowed orange
with the fire of countless burning buildings.
He needed to find more answers.
He needed to uncover the reason the SCP Foundation
was trying to wipe out humanity.
He had learned a lot from Site-19, and was
sure that if he could just get to the next
site, he would finally be able to figure out
the Foundation’s motive, and maybe even
how to stop them.
He took a step forward but his heads up display
suddenly went completely dark.
The suit constricted tighter around his body,
slowing the blood flow to his brian.
He couldn’t move as his vision got dimmer,
and dimmer, and dimmer, until he blacked out.
Pietro woke to find himself halfway across
the country.
It had been three months since he had been
at Site-19, and he had no recollection of
anything that had happened since.
His body had taken a toll in those months.
He had new scars and a bandage wrapped around
his head, but the SCP-5000 suit did not seem
to have a scratch on it.
Strangest of all though, was the briefcase
that Pietro had in his hand, and the uncontrollable
need to deliver it to the mysterious SCP-579.